around five to ten percent of all
children are born with dyslexia in
school they tend to read slowly have
difficulty understanding simple texts or
make a lot of spelling mistakes when
writing now while they are as
intelligent as others having received
years of instruction doesn't change the
fact that their brains struggle
organizing symbols in their heads
minds of children with dyslexia may
switch numbers when reading swap letters
as they appear or skip words when
writing some see their handwritten
letters backwards and others struggle
with grammar rules spelling correctly is
often impossible
before we learn what to do about that we
can hear the true story of a dyslexic
boy who overcame his weakness used his
disability to an advantage and became a
self-made billionaire
[Music]
once upon a time there was a boy named
ingvar he grew up on a small farm invas
grandfather died after realizing he
could no longer afford to pay the
mortgage but the grandmother's
dedication and hard work saved the farm
and the boy learned that perseverance
can lead to a better life and a better
life he wanted
but when in var started school he
struggled and at one point his father
told him he would never amount to
anything what nobody knew back then was
engvar had dyslexia inherited from his
ancestors just like the color of his
hair
[Music]
regardless he didn't let his problems
get him down and at age six inghvar
started selling single matches to his
neighbors soon after he asked his aunt
in stockholm to send him matches from
the wholesale market
ingvar then split the boxes into smaller
packages and resold them at a greater
profit
seeking his father's support the young
entrepreneur soon reached an entirely
new level
by the age of 10 ingvar would cross the
neighborhood on his bicycle selling fish
and pencils at 14 he sold belts watches
and wallets stocked under his bed at his
boarding school
in 1943 when he was 17 years old his
father helped him to register his
company he named it after himself ingvar
kamprad plus the initials from the farm
and village he grew up in
expanding his line of furniture ingvar
soon had trouble dealing with the
product codes to help him overcome his
weakness he created a system where he
instead of numbers gave names to each
object tables were named after places
garden chairs after islands
now ingvar was able to remember and
visualize each product by making
shopping memorable ikea became the
world's largest furniture company and
ingvar kamprad one of the richest men in
the world but not all children are as
lucky as our protagonist and some need
our support
[Music]
to help children with dyslexia we can
strengthen their speech perception which
children begin to form at about six
months old when they start to pay
attention to the sounds of spoken
language this usually happens as they
focus on the movements of their parents
lips to link visual with auditory input
lip reading is important because our
mind usually prioritizes what we see
over what we hear
[Music]
children who were raised with little to
no exposure to one-on-one conversations
can have problems connecting auditory
inputs with lip and tongue movements
some may not even realize that it takes
a completely different mouth tongue and
lip movement to produce letters as
similar as b and d they lack what's
called phonological awareness and if
they are also dyslexic they have it
especially hard
[Music]
practicing phonological awareness can
help children train their minds to
understand their own mouth movements
sounds and word structures hence
professional therapists often focus
first on the basics such as speaking and
listening only later do they move on to
the more complex forms of communication
such as reading and writing
by the way in finland children learn
reading at age six or seven and only
four percent are diagnosed with dyslexia
kids in the uk
start school at age 4 but the national
health service estimates 10 to be
dyslexic
later finnish students rank top as the
world's most literate people while
british pupils rank somewhere in the
middle
what are your thoughts about and
experiences with dyslexia did your
teachers punish kids for making spelling
mistakes or did they try to help them
share your thoughts in the comments
below
to experience phonological awareness
yourself do the famous mcgurk effect
experiment it demonstrates how our
visual perception beats our auditory one
and shows the importance of one
one-on-one conversations links are in
the descriptions
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below if you want to support
our mission and help change education
visit our patreon that's patreon.com
sprouts